Let's review what we've
covered in this course.
First, we discussed the strategy for
solving a business problem,
and stressed the importance
of understanding the problem,
the analysis needed, the decisions that
would be impacted by the analysis, and
the data that is needed
to support the analysis.
In short, spending time up front
to understand the problem and
the data available will help
ensure quality analysis.
Second, we reviewed some of
the non-predictive analysis techniques.
And third, we reviewed a process to help
you understand the different types of
predictive models, and used
the methodology map to help determine
which model is best suited for
a particular business problem.
Then we returned to our
example business problem, and
followed the problem solving framework,
and the strategy for
selecting a model, while also learning
about Linear Regression along the way.
Congratulations, great work and
you're now ready to build
your first predictive model